the drinks were about to make our bright
colorful and full of character which is
exactly how you want your Halloween
party to be hello I'm Hannah Hart and
today we'll be learning how to make some
extra spooky Halloween cocktails this
first drink looks like it was made by a
mad scientist it's green it's in a
beaker mainly it's a beaker part to make
this drink all it takes is some sour
apple liqueur a little vodka and a dash
of your favorite green sports drink use
this as an opportunity to loosen up for
the night ahead
next pour it into our stylish very cool
beaker and garnish with some extra
special sour candies as an adult you
have to find new ways to enjoy Halloween
so why not have a little fun with it our
next cocktail turns candy corn into
something actually edible first we're
gonna take our candy corn and use it to
infuse vodka let it sit for about an
hour or so cocktails are a lot like the
holidays they're about celebration and
they're about bringing people together
then we're going to take our infused
vodka and very gently pour it over the
back of a spoon to layer our liquids I
really love Halloween because it's a
community holiday it brings your
neighborhood together and if you don't
have kids it's a great way to bring all
your friends over to get dressed up and
frankly play Halloween is a great time
to express your creative urges by
transforming yourself for a day let's
say you're throwing a Halloween party
but you don't know your neighbors this
is a great time to get to know them in
my new cookbook my drunk kitchen
holidays how to savor and celebrate the
year I wanted to make a guide that would
last you all year long also I wanted to
give a shout out to some of the
lesser-known holidays like left-handers
day middle child's day play God day the
book is full of recipes essays and the
occasional crafter - just to make sure
that you're enjoying your holidays all
year long and if you're someone like me
who doesn't come from a lot of holiday
traditions this book encourages you to
make new traditions that are for you and
the family that you found if the idea of
coming up with some creative costume or
cocktail stresses you out don't be
stressed even the simple things can get
very creative pour it over some ice and
top it off with a splash of ginger ale
and there you have it a drink fit for a
vampire or as my people say that
be it and last but certainly not least
it's a delicious spicy smoky potion how
do you make it well first things first
we'll be making a sage simple syrup this
is basically just heating up water sugar
and sage strain your syrup and set it
aside and now you're ready to make your
cocktail this cocktail is basically a
margarita will be using mezcal lime
juice and a very dark tart juice of your
choosing for me I chose pomegranate this
cocktail is great for cardio it involves
lots of shaking so shake shake shake it
up and then you're ready for the fun
part do a little dance to get ready for
the night ahead
this drink is served up but there's a
twist we'll be using dry ice to give it
that extra spooky smoky potion effect
and finally we're gonna be garnishing it
with an adorable cinnamon stick and two
sage sprigs now it looks like a poison
apple I know it's really great this
cocktail looks super cool but make sure
to wait until it's completely done
smoking before you enjoy this potent
potion let's go take a minute I mean I
think these turned out pretty great
they're very colorful they're very
festive and they're delicious so enjoy
one at your next party or home alone
with your cats
oh yes
you